[Music]
yes I used to live here
won't you come in it's the least I can
do is it like you remember cleaner well
you feel free to look around while I get
the water boiling your hair is winter
fire
[Music]
[Music]
there you go awesome music I do
apologize but that's all very hot here
this time of year it's fine what do you
feel like you could just about die but
you know what they say about dairy hmm
no one who dies here ever really dies
but tell me how is it being back in
Derry it's got a strange strange oh my I
had some cookies in the oven before you
came Steve right there I shouldn't
impose I'm gonna no no no no no I insist
we photos a lovely miss Kirsch are these
your family my father came to this
country with 14 dollars in his pocket
what did he do mrs. Kirsch my father
joined the circus
I was always daddy's little girl what
about you are you still his little girl
Beverly are you
[Music]
smear the losers club is officially
begun
[Music]
we can do this but you have to stick
together
[Music]
hello
[Music]